on est heureux ici n'est ce pas jeter
tout au plus que tout ce qui existe
notre ville deviendrait un lieu consacré
au seigneur nous pouvons en faire un
paradis sur terre
des croque morts
j'ai besoin de ses services pour des
funérailles privées
est ce que tu crois que ça pourrait être
intéressant
qui doit chanter vrai pourquoi est-ce
que le croque mort et la délivrer pour
tempérer des landes
voulez-vous me prendre pour amy
[Musique]
jeter ce prix d'un bien gentil voiliers
du zoo alors voilà comment je vois les
choses et ramener autant de buts que tu
pourras tu es d'accord et des gens
m'avaient c'est le comble d'aisé vient
de faire une grave erreur en sortant
dans le ciel qui passe son prix
les coupables doivent être punis gerif
avant qu'il ne fasse de notre ville un
enfer il faut qu'on quitte cette ville
avant qu'il soit trop tard
c'est en tout cas
vous avez reçu trente deniers d'argent
cette fière de vous c'est chacun pour
soi dans cette ville depuis le temps
d'une dans les pas encore rendu compte
vous ne laissez pas satan entrer dans
cette église
je te regarde dans les yeux je marque de
la peur et comment ce portage de l'ieee
cous
quand je te regarde je vois plus de la
peur
johann n
[Musique]